Let's check in with, uh, oh, you know who's
on the phone?
You list these is on the phone.
Who is a DACA recipient and it's been, uh,
almost six months since we heard from Ulysses.
Hey, you'll listen.
How are you?
Hello?
I'm good.
Good, good.
So what's new, right?
And, uh, I just, you know, I just had a renewal
underway.
You did?
Okay, good.
That's fantastic.
Yeah, I just got a question for you.
Okay.
But you don't sound that happy about the DACA
Renewal?
No, no, no.
I am happy.
I'm just tired and I was just in the morning.
I gotcha.
Yeah.
As we got a question for you.
Sure.
Um, I just wondering what's like the, um,
the main root of antisemitism, do you think,
does it have to do with the killing of Jesus
Christ or do you think it's something else?
Yeah, I don't think it's the coming of Jesus
Christ.
Now, listen, Jews have been convenient scapegoats
for a really long time and there's been a
feedback loop where the ways in which Jews
were discriminated against perpetuated circumstances
that led to further discrimination.
So like, let me give you an example.
You have all of these conspiracy theories
now about, uh, Jews conspiring to control
certain industries, so on and so forth.
That is, uh, something that has come from
prior discrimination against Jews where they
were not allowed to participate in society
and a whole bunch of different areas which
pushed them into fields that require or benefit
from sitting around reading and discussing
and thinking about stuff.
So it's been this very unfortunate circle,
uh, where Jews have been scapegoated for something
and then they're scapegoating and discrimination
against them, furthers the feedback loop such
that there are new things for which they are
scapegoated and discriminated against.
And I, I don't think, you know, the, the entire
killing Jesus thing seems a little like a
cartoonish sort of not really practical reason
for modern antisemitism.
[inaudible]
Romans that killed Jesus to the extent that
Jesus existed.
I don't even know.
I mean, yeah, but, um, and I don't know too
much about the killing.
I mean, I don't know.
It's just, I think that's just like Bible
scholars.
I'd be hearing hearing that stuff from.
I got Ya.
Yeah.
And do you
do, why do you, do you also think that Islamic
caries also he Jews?
Cause
but many of them are antisemitic.
Yes.
Yes, absolutely.
Nope.
D why, why is that?
Cause I, I'm not understanding that
you'd have, you'd have to ask them, but it's
extremist Islam, uh, is not particularly fond
of the Jews, that's for sure.
Yeah.
All right.
You'll listen to this.
Thank you.
I really am glad that you got your DACA extension
though.
I really, that that's a great thing.
Yeah.
Thank you.
Alright, Ulysses, we'll talk to you soon.
Take care.